i could tell you about sir duncan at all
those were always your favorites i have
to do this
i have to do a prequel
um so i started thinking about my
history and
what would be a good area to write it
and i came up with the the duncan egg
stuff i was particularly attracted
that whole story is built around a
tournament and i love medieval
tournaments and they're reading about
them writing about them there's
of course some of them in the main the
main books
uh but this this was an opportunity in a
time of peace not
war to look at a medieval tournament
with all its pageantry and the jousting
and the combat
and reveal little of westerosi history
so this is the famous book of brothers
all the great deeds of all the great
kings girlfriends
so duncan the tour
four pages for sir duncan it must have
been quite a man so they say
all boys dream of becoming knights the
boys with talent dream of becoming
kingsguard
the boys without talent well i wouldn't
know
for centuries the kingsguard had been
the glory of the realm
aegon the conqueror had established the
order as his personal guardians after
uniting westeros with fire and blood
he knew that some of his subjects
wouldn't take to conquest
and his dragons were no use against
knives in the dark
no doubt surrounding himself with the
greatest knights in westeros made his
rule more palatable and less foreign as
well
everyone in his kingdom soon knew the
names and sung the songs of the
kingsguard
i certainly did from earliest days we
protected the king and his family
we killed his enemies and led his armies
we gave him counsel when asked and kept
his secrets when not
we swore to hold no lands take no wives
and father no children like
the night's watch except for the real
job to do
was i ordered to see my name inscribed
in the same book as my heroes
of course not i was 16 and brilliant
i knew it belonged there beside the name
of sir duncan the tall who as a hedge
knight broke several of prince aryan
targaryen's teeth while defending a
dornish woman
he later rose to lord command and burned
beside his king at summerhall
because sir duncan had sworn our oath
justice is a funny thing for the poor is
what keeps them alive
and starving depending on how the local
lord feels about his woods
his streams his crops for the rich
justice is what you get if you're not
careful enough or rich enough
usually how it works is you commit a
crime and the local lord sends his
guards after you
or your victim's family kills you and
the guards go after them instead
or you do nothing and the guards come
after you anyway either way
someone is bought before the lord and he
decides what's to be done
could be a fine if you're rich enough to
pay otherwise it's the dungeons the
chopping block
or the wall if your family honour goes
back hundreds of years to a time when
your ancestors hit other men harder than
they were hit
you have another option trial by combat
you either fight your accuser or you
both pick champions to fight on your
behalf
and the gods will favor the righteous
man
as long as he's also the strongest the
quickest or the luckiest
once in a long while you may get two
real high born shits having to go at
each other
and one of them might be full enough to
demand a trial by seven
exactly how it sounds seven men against
seven men
makes for a good show i guess but any
man who's been in battle
knows that the more men involved the
less skill needed the more chance of
accidents
just ask that targaryen prince who got
his head staved in by his brother all
those years ago
and all for some hedge night a wheel
with two hubs will not turn and a
kingdom with two kings will
burn as the saying goes not that such a
cost ever stopped anyone with even the
remotest claim and opportunity
much less house black fire
their rebellions consumed tens of years
and thousands of lives
first damon's own then his son
damon ii who reigned for a night then
another son hagon crowned by bittersteel
another legitimized great bastard who
had founded the golden company to
support the blackfyre claim
when aegon was executed bittersteel
crowned hagan's eldest son
damon iii who in turn was slain by their
lord commander of the kingsguard
sir duncan the tall the war of the nine
penny kings they called it
but i never saw a king who earned a
penny after the war ended i heard it all
started when an exiled royal bastard
raised an army of cell swords
and the rightful king sent his own army
to stop an invasion
sounds simple the way the masters tell
it but an army isn't like a dog that
comes when you whistle
the king calls on great lords who call
on lesser lords
who send out their captains to round up
all the peasant men on the land the lord
claims to own
if the lord is wise and generous his new
soldiers are given steel swords and
wooden shields to fight his battles
most of our army fought with sharp
sticks
singers still sing of the valiant heroes
made in the war
sir brynden tully the blackfish sir
tywin lannister
and prince aries targaryen sir barristan
selmy the bold who slew the bastard
pretender
and ended the war at a stroke but the
king whose crown we were defending never
came he mattered too much i suppose
his hand commanded the crown's armies
and died valiantly in his son's arms
or so the singers say i never saw that
either
i did see the soldiers when they came to
our village
they declared i was too young to fight
but my brothers and friends were all
going and i wouldn't be left behind
my oldest brother said i could be his
squire
though he wasn't a knight just a pop boy
on with a stolen kitchen knife
he'd never need it i saw him collapse on
the march from fever along with many
from our village
i saw our shoes fall apart on the road
our clothes rot
off our bodies and half of us [ __ ]
our beds from the sickness and fear
and then we got to the wall in the
stepped stones
i saw a mace cave in my last brother's
head i saw the lord who led us there cut
down on some other lord's shout that we
were is now
one day i looked around and realized all
my friends and kin were gone
that was fighting besides strangers
under a banner i'd never seen
didn't know where i was or how to get
home when a lord rode up
shouting at us to form ranks with our
size and holes i couldn't remember which
side it was on
then the knights came down on us
spaceless men
all in steel and the thunder of their
charge filled the world
i closed my eyes years later
after the war had faded into songs i
opened them again and saw what i had
done
and what i had become in the war and
since
i went looking for a way back home
i know i'll never reach it but that
doesn't mean i don't need a guide
according to legend house targaryen
survived the doom of valyria thanks to
danis the dreamer who foresaw the
calamity and convinced her father to
flee their homeland
it could be true the targaryens were
always a bit
more but as mr yendle points out
in the east the targaryens are one of a
thousand minor noble families
and in westeros they became kings
politics
not prophecy could have drawn them to
our shores
politics can also explain the prophecies
of damon blackfire ii
a targaryen bastard rumored to possess
the family gift
while posing as a hedge knight he told a
future lord commander of the kingsguard
that he dreamt of a dragon hatching at
white walls castle
and took it as a sign that he'd win the
iron throne
perhaps if he'd slept a bit longer he'd
dreamt of the king's hand putting down
his rebellion a day later before it even
began
most maesters dismiss all targaryen
claims of prophecy as mystic nonsense
a relic of their eastern ancestry
to be fair across the narrow sea there
isn't a market without a wall up from
carth telling fortunes or a
shadow binder from a shy reading fates
in blood
or so i hear from the maesters
the targaryens never stopped trying to
revive their dragons
aryan bright flame drank a draft of
wildfire
and burned to death aegon v tried to
hatch stone dragon eggs with sorcery
and burned to death
some said you wanted to see me who are
you
my father was micah
the first of his name my brother
reigned after him when i had
refused the throne
what are you telling him now only what
the little lord wants to hear
get your supper i want some time with
him
mm-hmm mother's looking for you
[Music]
hey